Die Digitalisierung durchdringt unsere Gesellschaft und die Nutzung informationstechnischer Systeme und des Internets schreiten unaufhörlich voran. Das bietet neue Chancen, schafft Freiräume und ermöglicht Synergien. Das Netz beeinflusst unser gesamtes öffentliches und privates Leben. Über Branchenquenzen hinweg sind mehr als die Hälfte aller Unternehmen in Deutschland vom Internet abhängig.
All diese Einrichtungen oder Firmen könnten gehackt werden.
Und ehrlich gesagt, das nenne ich sorglos.
Wir sind ein attraktiver Arbeitgeber.
Warum?
In manchen Bereichen unseres Hauses kann man all das machen, was man schon immer machen wollte, aber man ist strafflos. Zum Beispiel Telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Herr Range hat eine Pressekonferenz einberufen und in der hat er gesagt, dass der Justizminister unerträglich in die Unabhängigkeit der Justiz eingegriffen hat. Das kann man auch übersetzen in den Satz bitte entlasse sie mich in den Ruhestand, Herr Justizminister.
Da bräuchte ich dann mal eine Krisennummer von Ihnen.
Ja und warum?
Verstehen Sie bitte, dass ich darauf keine Antwort geben möchte.
Warum?
Ein Teil dieser Antworten würde die Bevölkerung verunsichern.
Lass mich ein Beispiel sagen.
Sie können ein sicheres Auto haben, mit Airbag. Sie können sich anschnallen. Sie können sich an die Verkehrsregeln halten. Wenn sie aber trotzdem sorglos fahren, produzieren sie einen Unfall.
Und da bräuchte ich dann mal eine Krisennummer von Ihnen. A32C3 Hast du dich auch schon an die 621-Regel gehalten?
Ich hatte meine Schwierigkeiten, aber ich glaube, heute habe ich sie erfüllt. Ich habe gerade noch mal schnell geduscht.
Also die Sendung mit dem perfekten Timing kündigt sich schon auf den ersten Metern an.
Zu unserem Gast ist eigentlich alles gesagt.
Wir schalten zurück ins Studio. Oder auch herzlich willkommen zu Logbuch Netzpolitik 165, live vom 32. Chaos Communication Kongress, direkt hier aus dem Sendezentrum mit euren Gästen. Hallo, willkommen bei uns.
Und vielen Dank für das Intro, natürlich an Krakow und Bense mit der Krisen-Nummer hier auf den Ehrenplätzen der ersten Reihe.
So, und ja, dann ist man wieder in dieser Situation, Linus. Man macht so eine Politquatsch-Sendung, die sich irgendwie die ganze Zeit mühsam durch die News durchpflügt. Und das will auch keiner hören, auch so im Kongress, oder?
Ja, bei dem Kongress ist ja dann der Kongress die News.
Dann reden wir einfach nur an Kongress.
Mach ich ja eh schon den ganzen Tag.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Bist du ganz gut eingebunden, oder? So, und weil wir halt total verzweifelt sind und eh keinen Plan haben, haben wir uns gedacht, laden wir uns einen Stargaz ein. Und die Wahl fiel auf Ulf Buermeyer. Hallo, willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Hallo, herzlichen Dank für die Einladung.
Den geneigten Logbuch-Hörer ist er natürlich kein unbekannter Gast, denn wir hatten dich schon mal dabei. Ich hab jetzt grad die Nummer nicht parat. In der 112, die Werbung des Nodens hast dich mit Linus unterhalten.
Genau.
Ich war da nicht dabei.
So war es. Das war schön.
Immer wenn es spannend wird, bin ich nicht dabei.
Ja, ich hab gehört ich war da Linus und Linus war Tim.
Deswegen war das ja so schön.
Ja, es geschehen manchmal wirklich merkwürdige Sachen in diesem Podcast. Aber heute können wir ja einfach mal eine klare Spur machen. Was wollten wir eigentlich machen? Also was sich natürlich immer anbietet, ist so eine Art Jahresrückblick. Aber so richtig jetzt einfach nur so durch die Monate durchackern, das ist ja mittlerweile auch schon ein beliebter Sport in den einschlägigen Postillen. Und ich denke, mit dieser Detailverliebtheit muss man das nicht machen. Aber trotzdem wollten wir schon noch mal einen Blick aufs Jahr werfen und mal gucken, ob sich eigentlich irgendwas geändert hat. Also ob irgendetwas jetzt jenseits von der täglich Gusters Murmeltier Politverschiebung in irgendeiner Form besser, schlechter, interessanter, dramatischer oder irgendwie spannender geworden ist. Mal vielleicht mal so gleich fünf Dimensionen aufzumachen. Das ist jetzt noch nicht ganz Trinktheorie, aber es hat schon auf jeden Fall mal Volumen. Womit fangen wir denn da an? Also ich meine, hast du dann, was würde dir denn als erstes einfallen?
Ich hab mir so ein paar Sachen überlegt natürlich vor der Sendung. Und eine gute Botschaft, finde ich, wollte ich mal an den Anfang stellen, damit wir so on a high note irgendwie anfangen können.
Ja, das haben ja Frank und Rob auch gerade so gemacht. Wir haben so den Weltuntergang. Angel, also du hier, Welt geht jetzt unter und so, aber munter bleiben.
Munter bleiben. Ich finde, es ist auch immer eine Frage der Haltung einfach zu den Dingen. Und es gibt immer genügend netzpolitische Katastrophenmeldungen, aber ich glaube, es lohnt sich auch auf die Dinge zu gucken, die mal gut laufen, weil die ja auch so ein Stück weit Mut machen können, dass es sich lohnen könnte, sich zu engagieren, zum Beispiel weiter zu diskutieren, zu werben für vernünftige netzpolitische Entscheidungen. Und ein Stichwort, das mir da so spontan einfällt, ist die ganze Landesverratsgeschichte. Das hat natürlich angefangen mit einem ziemlichen Skandal, also mit den Ermittlungen gegen Andre und Markus von netzpolitik.org. Aber wenn man sich das Ganze mal aus der Ergebnisperspektive anguckt, finde ich, dann ist Landesverrat wirklich ein Erfolg auf ganzer Linie, natürlich für das Blog zum einen, aber auch so für die netzpolitische Landschaft. Denn was eigentlich niemand mehr bezweifelt ist, dass Blogger, die journalistisch arbeiten, die sich also an bestimmte Qualitätsstandards halten, zum Beispiel ernsthaft recherchieren, dass Blogger Journalisten sind. Und das war vorher überhaupt nicht klar. Das war vorher natürlich auch eine Forderung, die viele erhoben haben, aber erst diese Landesverratsaffäre hat das eigentlich völlig klar gemacht. Durch die Solidarität natürlich der anderen Journalisten, der quasi Profi-Journalisten, aber auch durch die juristische Diskussion. Also selbst dieser Brief, der da aus Karlsruhe kam, durch den Andre und Markus überhaupt erfahren haben, das gingen sie ermittelt wird, selbst dieser Brief ging schon davon aus, dass diese beiden Blogger als Journalisten im rechtlichen Sinne anzusehen sind. Und das finde ich ist einfach ein Punkt, den man schon mal festhalten kann und ein großer Erfolg dieser Landesverratsgeschichte.
Was ja ganz interessant ist, weil die sich ja selber eigentlich auch, Frank und Frey, auch als Lobbyisten verstehen.
Ja, das ist in der Tat gerade bei Netzpolitik ja so eine Zwitterfunktion, klar. Aber Lobbyisten, weiß ich nicht, ob sie diese Bezeichnung gelten lassen würden, denn ich meine, es gibt keine klare Lobby-Definition, soweit ich weiß.
Ja gut, aber sie haben ja eine politische Agenda, das ist ja zu sagen. Offensichtlich, das kann man ja nicht abstreiten. Sie sind ja jetzt nicht in diesem Schaumbad der vollkommen ausgewogene Neutralität, in der sich vor allem die öffentlichen Medien immer ganz gerne baden sehen. Den Schritt gehen sie nicht. Ich denke auch nicht, dass das unbedingt ein Widerspruch ist. Also man kann ja für politische Dinge eintreten, aber trotzdem journalistische Standards an die eigene Arbeit, insbesondere in dem Moment, wo man so eine konkrete Postille betreibt, wie in dem Fall halt das Blog, auch walten lassen. Zumindest was eben die Anspruchshaltung an Recherche und Methoden und Absicherung von Quellen etc. und den entsprechend getätigten Aussagen betrifft.
Also ich hätte mit diesem Stichwort Lobbyismus deswegen ein Problem, weil ich da immer empfinde zumindest, dass Lobbyismus im Prinzip für Geld gemacht wird. Das sind Leute, die eine bestimmte politische Agenda verfolgen, weil sie dafür bezahlt werden. Und das ist ja gerade anders bei den Leuten, die Netzpolitik machen. Natürlich versuchen sie davon zu leben. Inzwischen gibt es ja auch einige Stellen in der Redaktion. Also es können Leute davon leben, Gott sei Dank. Aber sie werden halt nicht dafür bezahlt, eine bestimmte Meinung zu vertreten, sondern im ganzen Gegenteil. Sie haben halt einfach netzpolitische Überzeugungen. Und Gott sei Dank wird man inzwischen dafür bezahlt, dass man auf dieser Agenda sinnvollen Journalismus betreibt.
Aber betreiben, das würde ich eigentlich schon ganz gerne nochmal festhalten, dass andere Journalisten machen das doch nicht anders. Also die haben ja auch irgendeine Form von politischer Überzeugung, für die sie irgendwie mit ihrem Journalismus eintreten. Also da jetzt ausgerechnet, Markus und André herauszunehmen, weil sie diese Haltung transparent machen, finde ich eigentlich sogar fast unangemessen.
Nee, man kann das auch. Man kann ja eine politische Agenda haben und journalistisch arbeiten, das muss sich nicht unbedingt widersprechen. Die Frage ist, wie offen steht man zu seiner Agenda? Ich glaube auch nicht an den neutralen Journalismus oder die neutrale Position, weil allein schon durch die Themen, die du wählst oder fallen, ist man schon ein Stück weit in der Wertung und Gewichtung. Das ist auch nicht falsch. Ich denke, das gehört auch dazu. Man muss ja jetzt nicht über alles berichten. Wenn da irgendwelche Idioten den Pfiff von sich geben, muss man ja jetzt auch nicht mal gleich hinterher tiradieren.
Das ist nebenbei auch nichts Neues, wenn man sich das mal überlegt. Vielleicht kennt das noch der eine oder andere den Vorwärts. Das ist die Partei-Zeitung der SPD. Natürlich hat der Vorwärts einen politischen Anspruch. Das ist quasi das Zentralorgan der sozialdemokratischen Partei Deutschlands. Da wird natürlich eine politische Agenda vertreten. Insofern wäre ich da im Grunde Berlinus zu sagen, jeder Journalismus ist immer irgendwie ein bisschen politisch. Sonst liegt es vielleicht eher in der Person des Journalisten. Da hat jeder seine eigene Agenda. Bei Netzpolitik ist im Grunde klar, das Medium hat eine bestimmte Linie. Aber ich bin da auch bei Linus, ich finde das völlig legitim, denn die Linie ist ja transparent. Es wird immer klar gesagt, uns bei Netzpolitik geht es um die Geltung von Grundrechten. Es geht im Zweifel für die Menschen. Was irgendwelche Konzerninteressen sind, ist im Zweifel nicht ganz so wichtig. Das ist, denke ich, die Grundhaltung, auf die es sich zurückführen lässt.
Aber Zeitungen bezeichnen sich dann als allgemein?
Ich weiß nicht, also jedenfalls die Zeitung gibt es seit ewigen Zeiten. So kennt man ja irgendwie Frakturschrift aus dem Geschichtsbuch.
Frakturschrift? Nee, sehe ich hier nicht.
Nee, aber es gibt anscheinend eine Homepage von vorwärts.
Ja, das finde ich schon mal bemerkenswert.
Oh, es wird die Cannabis-Debatte geführt. Donnerwetter.
Hier gibt es auch Blogs.
Das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel für ein dezidiert politisches Medium. Oder ein Medium mit einer politischen Agenda, und dass es eben keine Neuigkeit ist.
So, die andere gute Nachricht. Andre und Markus sind nicht im Knast. Können wir eigentlich auch uns freuen?
Können wir in der Tat. Und erfreulicherweise ist es auch so, dass die Spenden angestiegen sind. Also es gab natürlich zum einen ganz akut Spenden. Wir wissen alle noch, im Juli, August trendete mal die E-Bahn von netzpolitik.org, also die Kontonummer. Das war natürlich ein großer Erfolg, und dabei ist auch eine Menge Geld zusammengekommen. Aber das hat sich auch Gott sei Dank verstetigen lassen. Ich habe gerade gestern noch mit Markus gesprochen. Also man sieht auch, dass quasi die monatlichen regelmäßigen Spenden eben doch sehr deutlich höher sind, als sie das vor der Affäre waren. Und das finde ich ist auch eine gute Botschaft, weil ganz offensichtlich es doch viele Menschen gibt in unserem Lande, die für unabhängigen kritischen Journalismus mit einer bestimmten Haltung auch bereit sind, ein bisschen Geld zu bezahlen. Das ist auch insofern eine schöne Geschichte, dass es nicht immer eine Paywall sein muss, sondern wenn man einfach wirklich ein Angebot macht, das die Leute überzeugt, dann ist es ihnen auch ein bisschen Geld wert. Und das finde ich eine sehr gute Nachricht.
Hatten wir noch weitere gute Nachrichten?
Ja, wir haben jetzt so ein paar Cliffhanger zwischendurch, die nicht ganz so großartig sind.
Wie bewertest du das denn, also dieser Sachverhalt des Landesverrats, das Vorgehen gegen Journalisten, das Vorgehen gegen bestimmte Veröffentlichungen? In Variationen sehen wir das ja immer wieder. Also wir haben diese ganze Wiki-Leaks-Geschichte. Ja, das geht auch nicht immer irgendwie so lustig und glimpflich aus. Wir haben auch ein paar Menschen auf lange Zeit in einen Knast oder in kleine äquadorianische Botschaften wandern sehen. Da ist Musik drin in dem Thema. Und dieses Thema des Whistleblower-Schutzes oder der Whistleblower-Kriminalisierung ist ja auch eins, was dich durchaus immer beschäftigt. Das ist doch mal ein Übergang.
Das ist in der Tat ein sehr schöner Übergang. Bei Landesverrat hat man gesehen, dass es eine große Solidarität gab, die einfach sehr breit war in der Bevölkerung und bei anderen Medien. Also die Pressefreiheit ist ein hohes Gut. Aber das schlägt nicht unbedingt notwendigerweise auch durch auf unsere Gesetzgebung. Und da sind wir beim nächsten Stichwort. Also wir haben ja in Deutschland immer noch keinen Whistleblower-Schutzgesetz. Gibt es nicht. Es gibt zwei Gesetzentwürfe, von den Grünen zum Beispiel, ich glaube auch von den Linken. Bislang aber hat keiner dieser Entwürfe es auch ans Bundesgesetzblatt geschafft. Mit anderen Worten, es gibt keinen klaren Whistleblower-Schutz. Ganz im Gegenteil. Quasi Huckepack auf diesem großen Gesetzespaket zur Vorratsdatensparierung gibt es noch ein neues Strafgesetz. Die sogenannte Datenhehlerei. Dieser Gesetzentwurf aus dem Hause Heiko Maas ist so unscharf formuliert, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass er eine große Gefahr sein kann für die Pressefreiheit. Die meisten Journalisten werden sich wohl selber nicht wegen Datenhehlerei strafbar machen, aber jedenfalls Leute, mit denen sie professionell zusammenarbeiten, um Daten auszuwerten. Vielleicht wollen wir das kurz erklären, worum es euch geht. Die Datenhehlerei ist ein neues Strafgesetz, das unter Strafe stellt, den Umgang mit Daten, die jemandem abhandengekommen sind. Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert. Nummer eins hat Daten, zum Beispiel einen Server. Diese Daten kommen abhanden. Nummer zwei bekommt die, zum Beispiel als Hacker oder als Mitarbeiter, der die Daten leaken will. Die kommen dann an eine dritte Person, zum Beispiel einen Journalisten. Diese dritte Person kann sich strafbar machen. Also nicht der Erste, der diese Daten zunächst mal aus der Firma rausbringt, zum Beispiel, oder aus der Behörde, der kann sich zwar auch strafbar machen, aber das ist kein Problem der Datenhehlerei. Nein, sondern Datenhehlerei betrifft dann immer diese Dritten, die erst mittelbar die Daten bekommen haben. Und das ist natürlich ein großes Problem. Also zum Beispiel Journalisten müssen ja ständig mit geleakten PDF-Dateien arbeiten. Das kennen wir aus der Redaktion von Netzpolitik, aber auch von großen Medien wie dem Spiegel. Und in der ersten Version dieser Datenhehlerei stand überhaupt nichts drin zum Thema Journalistenschutz. Und daraufhin haben wir das verblockt auf Netzpolitik und dann ist der Gesetzentwurf so ein bisschen nachgebessert worden. Das heißt also, hauptamtliche Journalisten können sich jetzt nicht mehr strafbar machen. Aber was ist denn zum Beispiel mit Hackern? Also wenn ich jetzt als Journalist ein Datenpaket zugespielt bekomme, dann kann ich das ja möglicherweise gar nicht selber auswerten. Praktisches Beispiel, diese Lavu-Affäre. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt. Heise hat vor ein paar Monaten mal Daten von dem Betreiber von Lavu, diesem Dating-Portal zugespielt bekommen, aus denen sich ergibt, dass die im Grunde so eine Art Bots betrieben haben, die männlichen Kunden vorgemacht haben, es gäbe Frauen, die sich für sie interessieren. Das waren aber nur Bots. Und man kann sich vorstellen, dass diese Bots dazu geführt haben, dass mehr Männer Lust hatten, irgendwie Geld für Lavu auszugeben. Und Heise hat dann da so ein bisschen recherchiert. Die haben natürlich insbesondere klären wollen, ob diese 40 GB Daten, die bei Lavu abhanden gekommen waren, ob die überhaupt echt waren oder ob das ein Fake war. Dazu mussten sie mit Hackern reden. Und wenn damals die Datenhehlerei schon gegolten hätte, dann wäre das nicht mehr klar gewesen, ob die sich überhaupt an Hacker wenden können. Also die Heise-Journalisten selber wären nicht strafbar gewesen. Möglicherweise aber eben die IT-Experten, die irgendwie die Outlook-Postfächer bewertet haben, ob die manipuliert worden sind oder nicht. Und da denke ich, das ist schon ein ganz großes Problem. Und das hat aber im Bundestag keinen so richtig interessiert, muss man ganz klar sagen. Und da kann man sagen, die Presse verhält. Klar, wird immer gerne Munde geführt, aber wenn es dann mal konkret wird, dann sieht es schon ein bisschen anders aus.
Was ich an diesem Absatz so interessant fand, oder an diesen Paragrafen, der ist ja schon sehr spezifisch formuliert. Da hat ja nicht jemand aus Versehen Quatsch geschrieben. Die haben sich ja wahrscheinlich sehr genaue Gedanken gemacht. Sind alle Gesetze so komplex? Eigentlich nicht. Ich habe ja ein paar schon gelesen und ich habe den Eindruck, dass die meistens einfachere Sachverhalte betreffen. Also unter den Sachverhalten, die Gesetze betreffen können, scheint mir das schon einer der komplexeren zu sein. Beinhaltet irgendwie drei aufeinanderfolgende Handlungen und so. Das schreibt wahrscheinlich nicht irgendjemand aus Versehen genauso. Und die werden sich doch was dabei gedacht haben.
Ich weiß es nicht so recht. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, klar, du hast recht, das ist extrem kompliziert. Das kann natürlich sein, dass sie sich das genauso kompliziert gedacht haben und dass da quasi perfide Gedanken dahinterstehen. Es kann aber auch sein, dass sie sich letztlich einfach verstrickt haben in der Komplexität ihres eigenen Gesetzes. Denn das hätte man ja auch deutlich einfacher formulieren können. Und insbesondere hätte man, das war ja auch so die rechtspolitische Gegenposition, hätte man das ja auch beschränken können auf Daten, mit denen in der Tat sinnvollerweise kein Handel getrieben werden sollte. Also, eigentlicher Sinn dieses Gesetzes, was auch in der Begründung ganz stark gemacht wird, ist zum Beispiel der Handel mit Kreditkartendaten. Und dass man mit solchen Daten nicht handeln darf, dass man die nicht weitergeben sollte, das macht aus meiner Sicht Sinn. Aber so hätte man zum Beispiel in dieses Gesetz ja einen Katalog reinschreiben können. Kreditkartendaten oder generell Zahlungsdaten, Logindaten, meinetwegen also bestimmte Daten, die eben besonders gefährlich sind. Aber das hat man nicht gemacht. Und da bin ich dann wieder bei Linus. Da frage ich mich schon, wenn man das wusste, und trotzdem das nicht eingeschränkt hat, und quasi bewusst in Kauf nimmt, dass das so Kollateralschäden für die Pressefeiert mit sich bringt. Tja, also ich kann da nicht mehr so richtig an einen Unfall denken. Zumal wir das ja auf Netzpolitik im Mai ausführlich verblockt hatten. Also Monate, bevor der endgültige Gesetzentwurf kam.
Ich glaube in dem Artikel hattest du auch geschrieben, letztendlich ist sogar die Absicht egal, weil wenn das Gesetz einmal da ist, dann ist die Absicht ohnehin unerheblich, sondern es gilt dann, was geschrieben ist. Und ich glaube du hattest gesagt, wenn ein Gesetz missverständlich ist, dann haben wir die Juristen dafür ausgebildet, das dann eben auch entsprechend auszulegen.
Ja, und man muss ja auch sehen, dass gerade bei Straftatbeständen die entscheidende Frage gar nicht immer ist, ob jemand auch wirklich verurteilt wird. Straftatbestände, also Strafgesetze entfalten ihre Wirkung ja auch schon im Ermittlungsverfahren. Also bei der Frage, kann ich zum Beispiel einen Beschluss erwirken, um eine Wohnung zu durchsuchen? Kann ich einen Beschluss erwirken, um eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung zu schalten? Und jede Unschärfe wirkt sich im Ermittlungsverfahren besonders dramatisch aus, einfach weil da ja nicht so genau hingeguckt wird. Also klar, da gibt es dann immer einen Ermittlungsrichter, der prüft den Fall natürlich genau, wie man weiß. Aber wie man auch weiß, werden diese Anträge ja fast nie abgelehnt. Mit anderen Worten ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach sehr gering, dass im Ermittlungsverfahren so Unschärfen eines Gesetzes dazu führen, dass Ermittlungsmaßnahmen abgelehnt werden. Normalerweise läuft das dann so durch. Und deswegen habe ich genau da auch in diesem Artikel auf Netzpolitik so sehr davor gewarnt, ein Gesetz zu erlassen, das eben missbraucht werden kann, um Journalisten zu verfolgen. Oder ihre Hilfspersonen. Journalisten selber sind jetzt heraus. Aus der Nummer aber eben zum Beispiel Hacker oder andere IT-Experten, die mit Journalisten zusammenarbeiten wollen.
Hacker und andere IT-Experten. Gibt es noch andere?
Ja, die Definition ist ja so ein bisschen unklar. Ja, stimmt.
Jetzt war es, waren, glaube ich, netzpolitik.org und du mit einigen Gastbeiträgen in, ich glaube, verschiedenen Medien so wirklich die einzigen, die da sich zu geäußert haben.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Habt ihr irgendeine Form von Antwort bekommen?
Ja, Heiko Maas hat im Bundestag in seiner Rede zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung zwei Minuten auf uns eingekloppt und gesagt, das sei alles Panikmache. Und der deutsche Journalistenverband hat immerhin eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, wo er ebenfalls davor gewarnt hat. Aber klar, das Problem ist halt, das war schon sehr geschickt gemacht oder man kann auch sagen, sehr perfide. Das ist ein klitzekleiner Teil dieses langen Gesetzentwurfes zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Natürlich hat sich das rechtspolitische Interesse auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung konzentriert. Diese Datenhebelreihe ist so quasi unter dem Radar durchgesegelt. Das hat niemand so richtig interessiert. Alle haben nur auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung geguckt. Und jetzt steht es da im Bundesgesetzblatt. Wir müssen irgendwie sehen, wie wir dieses zerschlagende Porzellan wieder zusammensetzen.
Wenn wir dann die Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Karlsruhe kassiert haben lassen, wird dann genau dieser Teil mit rausfliegen, weil das nach dem Alles-oder-Nichts-Prinzip läuft? Oder könnte dieser Teil unter Umständen sogar einfach bestehen bleiben?
Der könnte grundsätzlich auch bestehen bleiben. Man muss sagen, dass so verfassungsrechtlich die Attacken gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung völlig anders laufen als die Attacken gegen die Datenhehlerei. Deswegen macht es aus meiner Sicht auch Sinn zu sagen, wer die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kritisiert, der kritisiert erst mal die und konzentriert sich auf deren Probleme. Und man greift die Datenhehlerei separat an. Und da gibt es ja auch schon vom Club Initiativen.
Und wie sicher bist du dir, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung die neue vom Verfassungsgericht stranden wird?
Oh, das ist eine ganz heikle Frage. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Da bin ich jetzt eher einer der Pessimisten. Das hängt glaube ich sehr viel oder sehr weitgehend davon ab, wie sich das Verfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe so positioniert, auch zu den Gerichten auf der europäischen Ebene. Man muss ja sagen, da gibt es auch schon so eine gewisse Konkurrenz. Und im ersten Durchgang war es ja so, dass die Karlsruhe die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zwar gekippt haben, aber nicht wegen ihrer Eingriffe in die informationelle Selbstbestimmung, also in den Datenschutz, sondern wegen Problemen bei der Datensicherheit. Also auf Deutsch die Server waren nicht strikt genug gesichert. Das war das Problem. Und die Eingriffe in den Datenschutz haben die Karlsruhe leider Gottes durchgewogen. Das ist so ein bisschen untergegangen. Wir haben alle gefeiert, als die erste Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekippt wurde. Aber das war, muss man sagen, wirklich allenfalls ein halber Sieg. Denn, dass eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit dem Grundgesetz angeblich vereinbar sein soll, haben die Karlsruhe eben auch gesagt. Die europäischen Richter waren da kritischer und haben jedenfalls gesagt, so bestimmte Berufsgruppen können von einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht erfasst werden. Zum Beispiel Anwälte oder Ärzte dürfen nicht erfasst werden anlasslos. Und das geht deutlich weiter, als das, was die Karlsruhe gesagt haben. Und jetzt muss man halt sehen, ob die Karlsruhe quasi wieder die Pole-Position beim Grundrechtsschutz erringen wollen. Wenn sie das wollen, müssen sie im Grunde über ihr Urteil von 2010 hinausgehen. Oder, was sie natürlich auch machen könnten, wäre den EuGH einfach zu fragen. Ja, aber das wäre ja möglich. Nationale Gerichte können ja Rechtsfragen dem Europäischen Gericht zur Vorabentscheidung vorlegen. Das wäre also eine Möglichkeit. Das hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht noch nie gemacht. Das hat natürlich auch so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, eine Frage der Eitelkeit. Dass man natürlich als höchstes deutsches Gericht nur sehr ungern ein anderes Gericht nach seiner Meinung fragt. Aber das wäre eine Möglichkeit, wie die Karlsruhe so dieses Dilemma für sich lösen können.
Und ist denn die Entscheidung von EuGH in irgendeiner Form fürs Bundesdeutsche Verfassungsgericht auch bindend, leitend, also es ist verpflichtend zu irgendetwas? Müssen die das berücksichtigen?
Das müssen die dann, ja.
Und was heißt das, dass die das berücksichtigen müssen? Die müssen sich das mal durchgelesen haben.
Ne, das geht schon weiter. Also das Berücksichtigen, das sind Entscheidungen vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Die müssen nur berücksichtigt werden. Und zwar, das hat so einen technischen Grund, die Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention gilt quasi so vom Rangverhältnis nur so viel wie ein einfaches Gesetz. Die steht also formal unter dem Grundgesetz. Und deswegen, auf der anderen Seite will man aber natürlich nicht gegen europäische Menschenrechte verstoßen. Deswegen hat man da mal entschieden, die Menschenrechtskonvention muss quasi bei der Auslegung des Grundgesetzes berücksichtigt werden. Das ist so der Kompromiss. Europäisches Recht von der EU hingegen bricht deutsches Recht. Das heißt, das geht auch dem Grundgesetz vor. Wenn der EUGH also sagt, der Europäische Gerichtshof, so etwas wie eine Vorratsdatensprechung geht gar nicht nach den europäischen Grundrechten, dann wäre es im Grunde egal, was im Grundgesetz steht. Dann müsste das Bundesverfassungsgericht das auch berücksichtigen. Also als Maßstab nehmen, nicht nur berücksichtigen.
Als Maßstab nehmen. Das wiederum würde ja unter Umständen dafür sprechen, dass sie auch ihre alte Rechtsprechung noch mal verschärfen oder vielleicht auch einen Teil remittieren. Wir wollen ja ein bisschen optimistisch bleiben. Also das ist wichtig. Guck mal hier, die Leute sind auch schon ganz verunsichert.
Ja, ich sehe das schon. Teile meiner Antwort haben Leute verunsichert.
Teile dieser Leute verunsichert.
Es gibt in der Tat natürlich auch Grund zum Optimismus. Ein schönes Stichwort ist die Überwachungsgesamtrechnung. Wir haben ja seit der Entscheidung 2010 im Fall Vorratsdatensprechung 1 haben wir ja ein bisschen was gelernt. Dank Edward Snowden wissen wir ja eine ganze Menge mehr über das Bigger Picture der Überwachung, der wir alle ausgeliefert sind. Und damals, 2010, haben die Karlsruhe gesagt, also diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung muss quasi eine ganz große Ausnahme bleiben. Das kann man jetzt nicht regelmäßig machen, man kann jetzt nicht 1000 Vorratsdatenspeicherungen einführen, sondern wenn überhaupt dann nur eine einzige. Das war 2010, Forced Note. Und nun haben wir ja erfahren, was alles ohnehin schon gespeichert wird, zwar zunächst mal vor allem von Internetunternehmen, aber wie man weiß, kann auf deren Daten zugegriffen werden, zunächst mal durch die NSA, aber die Dienste sprechen miteinander. Und das ist, denke ich, eine der zentralen Argumentationen, wie man auch den Karlsruhern plausibel machen kann. Leute, ihr müsst noch nicht mal unbedingt eure Rechtsprechung ändern. Ihr müsst im Grunde nur anwenden, was ihr damals gesagt habt. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung muss eine Ausnahme bleiben. Und wenn schon das passiert, was Snowden uns beschrieben hat, Stichwort Prism zum Beispiel, dann kann es eigentlich nicht sein, dass so was wie eine zweite, diesmal staatliche Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt wird. Das wäre eine denkbare Argumentationslinie.
Wer verfolgt denn jetzt die Argumentationslinie? Welche Bewegungen gibt es da so? Wir haben glaube ich die, so um die Digitalcourage herum.
Genau, meiner Statistik und Patrick Breyer und so.
Genau, das ist eine Verfassungsklage. Und dann gibt es noch eine Verfassung, ne, das ist eine Verfassungsbeschwerde. Und dann gibt es doch noch eine Anstrengung von Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Ja, soweit ich weiß, ist das aber auch eine Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Da ist jetzt technisch erstmal kein entscheidender Unterschied.
Genau, soweit ich das verstanden habe, wollen die auch eine Verfassungsbeschwerde erheben und damit dann eben direkt das Bundesverfassungsgericht abführen.
Kannst du vielleicht mal in wenigen Worten den Unterschied zwischen Klage und Beschwerde in dem Zusammenhang deutlich machen?
Es gibt keine Verfassungsklage technisch. Es gibt im Prinzip, wenn man nach Karlsruhe will, ein bestimmtes Set an juristischen Instrumenten. Und das bekannteste ist in der Tat die Verfassungsbeschwerde, weil die prinzipiell jeder Mann erheben kann oder jede Frau. Und dann gibt es aber noch ganz bestimmte andere verfassungsrechtliche Klageformen. Es gibt zum Beispiel eine abstrakte Normenkontrolle, die aber nur ganz bestimmte Institutionen erheben können. Oder zum Beispiel gibt es auch die sogenannte Richtervorlage. Also wenn ein Richter einen Fall zu entscheiden hat und er glaubt, ein Gesetz, auf das es in diesem Fall ankommt, ist nicht mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar, dann kann der Richter diesen konkreten Fall wiederum nach Karlsruhe verweisen, weil Karlsruhe ein Monopol darauf hat, Gesetze für Verfassungswidrig zu erklären. Also ein Richter kann nicht einfach sagen, das Gesetz wende ich jetzt nicht an, weil er denkt, das ist verfassungswidrig. Das kann nur Karlsruhe. Und dann muss er diesen Fall quasi in Karlsruhe vorlegen zur Entscheidung. Das passiert aber ganz selten, weil die Karlsruher fast immer sagen, lieber Richter, du hast das Gesetz falsch verstanden. Also fast immer kriegt der Richter dann links und rechts eine Ohrfeige. Er hat angeblich nicht genau genug hingeguckt und es kommt angeblich auf diese Entscheidung Karlsruhe ist gar nicht an in seinem Fall. Deswegen hat kein Richter darauf Lust, Gefälle vorzulegen. Alter, guck mal, ist doch wohl klar. Guck mal hin. Mach jemand nicht auf wichtig. Das ist so ein bisschen immer die unausgesprochene Botschaft. Man nimmt dich mal nicht so wichtig, mach mal. Und wenn es wirklich schlimm ist, dann steht schon einer Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Oh man ey, Rap-Battle im Verfassungsgericht.
Und jetzt würde mich noch mal kurz interessieren, in Österreich war das doch, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, so, dass der höchste österreichische Gerichtshof dann diesen Fall zur Vorratslandenspeicherung an den EuGH gegeben hat. Und das heißt, das war ein Fall, wo der höchste Gerichtshof eben über seinen eigenen Schatten gesprungen ist und gesagt hat, jo, geben wir dorthin weiter. Was wäre, wenn jetzt das Bundesverfassungsgericht die deutsche Vorratslandenspeicherung II für vollkommen in Ordnung urteilt? Ich aber der Ansicht bin, dass es vor dem nach EuGH Maßgabe eigentlich aus irgendwelchen Gründen eingeschränkt werden müsste. Kann ich dann an dem Bundesverfassungsgericht vorbei irgendwie an den EuGH kommen?
Das ist genau das Problem. Es gibt keine sogenannte Individualbeschwerde zum EuGH.
Das heißt, das Bundesverfassungsgericht könnte quasi ungestraft Maßgaben des EuGH brechen und dann wäre die einzige Sanktionsmöglichkeit irgendwie Strafzahlungen an die EU-Kommission? Wie wird da sichergestellt, dass wir uns nicht einfach über die schönen europäischen Maßgaben hinwegsetzen?
Also das ist in der Tat eine sehr komplexe Frage. Kann ich ganz einfach nicht beantworten, einfach weil der Fall noch nicht vorgekommen ist. Grundsätzlich kann natürlich die EU-Kommission Vertragsverletzungsverfahren einleiten. Da müsste sie allerdings der Meinung sein, dass das deutsche Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz gegen europäisches Recht verstößt. Das ist natürlich theoretisch denkbar. Und es gab ja auch, ich weiß nicht, ob das der eine oder andere mitverfolgt hat, dank netzpolitik.org wissen wir das nämlich. Es gab eine Notifizierung, also die Bundesregierung hat das Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz vorlegen müssen in Brüssel, damit die da mal drüber gucken und vorab ihre Meinung sagen können. Und diese Meinung war durchaus kritisch. Das Dokument ist nämlich geleakt worden auf Netzpolitik. Und daher wissen wir, dass die EU-Kommission massive Bedenken hat gegen die deutsche Vorratsdatenspeicherung, gerade wegen der Entscheidung des EUGH. Aber sie haben jetzt nicht direkt mit dem Vertragsverletzungsverfahren gedroht. Das muss man verabwarten. Es gibt aber natürlich noch andere Möglichkeiten. Also wenn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung irgendwann mal in Kraft ist zum Beispiel, dann könnten Bürgerinnen und Bürger, die damit nicht einverstanden sind, auch gegen ihre Provider klagen und sagen, lieber Provider, du darfst gar nicht speichern. Zwar gibt es dieses deutsche Gesetz, aber das ist europarechtswidrig. Und dann könnte man hoffen, dass diese Zivilgerichte, vor denen dieser Fall dann landet, wiederum den Fall beim EuGH vorlegen. Und natürlich gibt es auch schon Überlegungen in diese Richtung. Also jetzt warten wir erstmal ab, was die Verfassungsbeschwerde ergibt. Aber man könnte durchaus auch nochmal weitere juristische Mittel und Wege finden, um den Fall zum EuGH zu bringen.
Also du bist nicht grundoptimistisch, dass es auf jeden Fall fällt, aber es gibt durchaus schon eine ganze Menge Anhaltspunkte, an denen das Ding wirklich am Haken hängen bleiben könnte.
Absolut. Und wenn es nicht sofort fällt, in Karlsruhe, dann wird es uns viele Jahre weiter beschäftigen. Das muss man sagen. Also was jedenfalls nicht passieren wird, ist, was ja glaube ich viele Befürworter der Vorratsentsprechung erhoffen, dass das Gesetz jetzt einfach mal durch ist und jetzt läuft das mal und dann regen wir uns alle nicht mehr auf. Das wird definitiv nicht passieren. Jedenfalls die nächsten Jahre wird es immer wieder Klagen dagegen geben. Und insofern, das Thema bleibt auf der Agenda, ganz klar. Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen...
Bis wir was zu reden haben, sonst fällt uns ja nichts mehr ein.
Ja, ich finde es auch wichtig, um den Leuten immer wieder klar zu machen, das ist einfach ein Problem, was da passiert.
Da immer wieder drüber reden zu müssen, das ist doch anstrengend.
Ja, man merkt es da nach Stimme an. Du hast wahrscheinlich schon mehrfach drüber geredet heute.
Ich hatte da gestern ein ganz interessantes Gespräch, wo jemand sagte, ja, ich war bei irgendeiner CDU-Veranstaltung, da war eine Politikerin, die eigentlich jetzt nichts großartig zu sagen hat, aber die konnte wunderbar darüber sprechen, wie gut Vorratslandenspeicherung ist und die hatte offenbar irgendeine Form von Handreichung oder sowas bekommen aus dem Konrad-Adenauer-Haus oder so und war offensichtlich irgendwie gebrieft. Da wurde vorgeschlagen, wir könnten das doch auch mal machen. Während ich dann so darüber nachdachte, da fiel mir dann auf, wie viele Veröffentlichungen gegen die Vorratsdaten-Speicherung es jetzt schon gegeben hatte. An Informationsheften, an Artikeln, an Demonstrationen, an hier willst du in 5 setzen, willst du in 6, willst du in 7, willst du in 8, willst du in A4, willst du in A5. Haben wir ja alles gemacht. Haben wir da eigentlich so ein Archiv, auf das wir zurückgreifen können? Oder ist es schon so, dass die Sachen, die Themen sich schon immer nochmal, die juristischen Argumentationen sich nochmal... Hört man mich noch?
Ja, irgendwas ist gerade komisch. Ich hör dich nicht mehr über den Monitor.
Ich hör mich auch nicht mehr.
Ralf, du machst uns die Kopfhörer leise. Was hast du getan?
Gut, dann rede ich einfach weiter. Dass wir...
Warte mal, ich helf mal.
Gibt's ein Archiv? Das war die Frage. Gibt's ein Archiv?
Das ist der Elektrosmog. Ich hab hier noch Klomoli.
Oh ja, tu mir mal lieber noch was ins Bier hier.
Ich dachte, du tust dir jetzt was im Trink.
Ja, das tue ich ja auch.
Elektrosmog Klomoli.
Ins BND-Breu.
Hab jetzt mehrere reingetan und es wird sehr nicht so stark.
Transparent.
Da muss man dann nicht weniger tun.
Das ist ja nicht gleich mit einem anfangen. Das knallt ja dann zu sehr.
Ich glaube, die ging es um ein Archiv der Argumente.
Kann man da Argumente aus dem Archiv holen, oder ist es dann doch wieder so durch neue Formulierungen, dass die juristische Argumentation dann doch wieder irgendwie in Nuancen anders geführt werden muss?
Ich glaube beides. Also man kann, oder die meisten Argumente spielen ja jetzt nicht auf einer präzisen juristischen Ebene, glaube ich, sondern eher auf so einer Art kriminalpolitischen. Also die zentrale Frage ist ja, bringt das jetzt eigentlich irgendwas? Bringt das was zur Kriminalprävention, bringt das was bei der Aufklärung von Straftaten? Und das lustige ist ja, dass es eben bislang jedenfalls keine empirischen Belege dafür gibt, dass es irgendwas bringt. Also es gibt einfach keine Statistik, die zeigt hier, schwuppdiwupp, Aufklärungsquote plus 10 Prozent oder plus 20 Prozent, im Gegenteil. Es gibt eben nur Studien, die sagen, es hat einfach keinen messbaren Effekt. Und das sind, denke ich, ganz zentrale Argumente, die auch immer weiter gültig werden oder gültig bleiben. Also ich denke, die neue Vorratsdatenspeicherung wird im Zweifel weniger bringen als die alte, einfach weil die Daten ja weniger lange gespeichert werden sollen. Wenn überhaupt wird sie weniger bringen.
Hatten wir überhaupt schon mal irgendwie, also ich, mir ist eigentlich kein Fall bekannt, dass mal in einem, dass ein Wirksamkeitsnav als einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung geführt worden wäre.
Ne, das ist genau das Ding, die EU-Kommission hat es ja versucht, ne, bei der Evaluation der Richtlinie und in ganz Europa gibt es keine einzige Statistik, die zu diesem Ergebnis gekommen wäre. Das ist genau das Problem und daraufhin hat die EU-Kommission ja davon abgesehen, diese ganzen Statistiken überhaupt im Detail zu veröffentlichen.
Da habe ich mich mit einem Vorsitzenden einer Polizeigewerkschaft mal drüber unterhalten. Oder eines Bundesverbandes, der mich dann sagte, wie erklärst du dir das denn bitte? Und dessen Antwort war ja, die Beamten müssten ja dann auch erstmal diese neuen Ermittlungsmethoden einsetzen und kennenlernen, bis sie sie dann eben gezielt und klug anwenden können. Das heißt, wir müssen also noch ein paar Jahre warten, bis die Polizeibeamten das Mittel der Vorratsdatenspeicherung so zur Anwendung bringen können, dass es auch wirkt.
Man muss nur lange genug warten, dann wird es schon irgendwann gut werden.
Das fand ich aber interessant.
Das ist so wie mit Bugs, wenn man einfach lange genug wartet, dann verschwinden die einfach. Dann werden die einfach alleine rausgepatcht.
Das stimmt. Ich frag mich nur eher, also dann...
Festplatten übrigens auch, wenn man die lange genug stehen lässt, dann haben die auch mehr Platz irgendwann.
Die wachsen mit quasi.
Ich fand das Argument nur deshalb so ein bisschen schwer nachvollziehbar, weil sie sich ja nicht zu schade sind, irgendwelche komischen Statistiken zu malen, die jetzt keine empirische Grundlage haben, aber die dann schön darstellen, dass ja wegen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung so und so viele Verbrechen begangen werden und wir alle dem Notstand ausgesetzt sind, wegen dem Mangel an Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ich glaube, wir müssen ja gleich mal das SEK einschreiten, weil da hinten wurde nämlich irgendwie das Badezimmer übernommen.
Das ist Toilettenparty.
Toilettenparty auf dem 32C3 ist natürlich auch mal geil.
Ist ja so ein Jugendherbergs-Teil.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sozusagen jetzt so das Äquivalent zum Campgenerator, den sie uns irgendwie in dem Sendezentrum gestellt haben. Jetzt kriegen wir irgendwie auch noch unseren eigenen Club nebenan.
Was kommt denn da eigentlich hier gerade aus der Seitenraube?
Keine Ahnung. Das kam jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal an, aber ich hab für ihn gedacht, das hätte keinen Inhalt für uns.
Das scheint mir Abfall zu sein, oder?
Da steht doch was drauf.
Ich weiß nicht. Das sind so Dinge, da muss man ja irgendwie...
Meinst du nicht, dass das streng riecht, eventuell?
Das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich finde, wir sollten jetzt das Thema Vorratssattenspeicherung einfach mal überspringen oder abschließen oder so.
Hatten wir auch schon mal.
Hatten wir gemacht, oder? Was wir, glaube ich, noch ansprechen sollten, ist Störerhaftung, oder? Weil das ja auch so ein Thema von dir ist, aber weil auch da ja Licht am Ende des Tunnels ist.
Stimmt's? Das ist wieder so ein High-Note-Thema. Ja. Da habe ich ja neulich auf Twitter gelernt, ein ganz fieser Lobbyist. Da hat mir so ein Urheberrechtslobbyist geschrieben, ich sei Lobbyist. Nein.
Für was denn?
Ein ganz fieser Lobbyist, ja für Freifunk. Mir wurde unterstellt, ich sei ein böser Freifunk-Beförder.
Ach, für den internationalen Großkonzern Freifunk AG?
Die Freifunk-Mafia hat mich gekauft, habe ich gelernt.
Das hat der nicht gesagt.
Nein, Mafia kommt jetzt von mir, aber das war so ein bisschen der Untertun, ja.
Von welchem Geld denn?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch. Ja, genau, da habe ich dann auch geantwortet, ich habe gesagt, naja, also Geld bekomme ich da nicht dafür. Im Gegenteil, wenn überhaupt, dann kriegen CCC und DigiGast Geld von mir. Und da meint er, naja, es gäbe ja auch unbezahlten Lobbyismus. Deswegen habe ich da eben so eingehakt, weißt du?
Sehr verwerflich, sehr verwerflich. Das sind die schlimmsten.
Das ist ja ganz schlimm.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich jetzt hier schon Terrorphase ausrufen muss oder nicht.
Das blaue Kabel, das sieht gefährlich aus. Ich glaube, das ist doch einfach nur die Beleuchtung, der Flasche.
Das ist nur die Beleuchtung. Ich wollte es nur ein bisschen bewundern, während ihr euch über Störerhaftung unterhaltet. Lasst euch einfach von mir nicht weiter ablenken, ich bau das jetzt wieder zusammen, schickts wieder zurück. Die Frage ist, warum haben wir das überhaupt gekommen? Das war wahrscheinlich für Verunsicherung.
Das ist ein verdächtiger Gegenstand.
Teile des Bausatzes und so.
Oh Gott, dem Witz, dem Dürfer 2016, der war ja irgendwie schon nach einem Tag so durch. Oder? Ich hab mich geschämt, jedes Mal, wenn ich so ein Witz gemacht hab.
Aber so richtig schlecht ist er irgendwie auch nicht.
Weil er halt so gut war, ist er halt binnen einer Woche wirklich, also Twitter glüht er das ja schon irgendwie innerhalb von 24 Stunden, dann hat sich noch Bümmermann der Sache angenommen und so weiter. Und dann war das halt einfach gerocht.
Teile des Witzes haben einen langen Wagen.
Siehst du, wie schlecht das funktioniert? Die Einschaltquoten gehen auch schon wieder zurück.
Störerhaftung.
Störerhaftung. Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, und ich hab so das Gefühl, dass die Länder ein bisschen aufgewacht sind.
Das kann man so sagen.
Dass das einfach so ein kommunales Landesding ist, dass die jetzt auf einmal anfangen zu verstehen, dass man das doch vielleicht mal hätte anders machen sollen.
Man muss sagen, es ist auch so ein kleiner Aufstand der SPD-Basis gegen Sigmar Gabriel. Also Sigmar Gabriel hat ja die Vorratsdatensprechung durchgeboxt, wohl jedenfalls gegen breite Kreise in der SPD. Und Sigmar Gabriel hat ja auch mehr oder weniger im Alleingang dafür gesorgt, dass eben nicht etwa der schöne Digigas-Gesetzentwurf oder der Gesetzentwurf der Grünen oder der Linken gesetzt wird, sondern er hat einen eigenen Gesetzentwurf vorliegen lassen von dem Wirtschaftsministerium, dessen Chef er ja ist, indem eben die Störerhaftung gerade nicht voraussetzungslos abgeschafft werden soll, sondern wo WLAN-Betreiber eine ganze Reihe von skurrilen Bedingungen erfüllen sollen, um quasi von der Störerhaftung befreit zu werden. Und da muss man einfach sagen, da haben die Landesregierung aus Baden-Württemberg und Nordrhein-Westfalen, also unter Grüne bzw. unter SPD-Führung im Bundesrat, so einen kleinen Aufstand inszeniert und haben gesagt, nein, das finden wir nicht in Ordnung, was die Bundesregierung, also Klammer auf, was Sigmar Gabriel, Klammer zu, da so inszeniert, sondern wir wollen die Störerhaftung einfach abgeschafft wissen und haben in der Sache eigentlich einen Änderungsantrag gestellt, der den Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung so umbiegt, dass er dann dasselbe sagt wie der Entwurf der Opposition oder der DigiGas schon vor drei Jahren. Und das, finde ich, ist schon eine bemerkenswerte Geschichte.
Und denkst du, das ist jetzt auch auf dem Weg?
Schauen wir mal, also die Union scheint wohl nicht mitzuspielen. Und dann ist die Frage, wie stark letztlich die Verhandlungsmacht der SPD in der Koalition sein wird. Als kleiner Koalitionspartner muss man das abwarten. Also wir hatten dazu ja vor zwei Wochen eine Anhörung im Bundestag, wo sich alle Experten eigentlich dafür ausgesprochen haben, das so zu machen, wie es der Bundesrat will, mit einer Ausnahme. Die CDU hatte nämlich auch den Betreiber eines kommerziellen Hotspot-Systems eingeladen. Ja, von Hotsplots. Und, oh, wir haben wieder Posten.
Jaja, sieht schon jetzt etwas gehaltvoller aus.
Oh, das sieht aber schön aus.
Das nehmen wir an.
Das nehmen wir an, das ist doch nett.
Ich habe so einen Verdacht. Wolltest du deinen Gedanken noch zu Ende führen, oder ist das schon weg?
Hotsplots, ja genau, das war sehr lustig. Es war also ein Betreiber eines kommerziellen Hotsplotsystems da. Und der fand das natürlich doof, dass die Störerhaftung abgeschafft wird, weil dann einfach weniger Leute seinen schönen Hotspot mieten. Aber ansonsten waren sich eigentlich alle einig, dass man doch die Störerhaftung mal abschaffen sollte. Und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, möglicherweise könnte sich als Kompromisslinie abzeichnen, dass man so eine Art Vorschaltseite braucht. Diese sogenannte Lügenseite, wo man also hochunheilig schwören soll, keine Rechtsverletzungen zu begehen. Das könnte der Kompromiss sein, dass man also nicht mehr haftet, sobald man eine solche Vorschaltseite hat.
Das habe ich aber jetzt auch schon öfter gesehen in so Cafés oder so. Totaler Stuss.
Ist Stuss und ist technischer auch meistens Murks.
Kann man aber schön wegautomatisieren. Wenn man dann einen schönen einheitlichen Standard dafür schafft, dann...
Dann geht da einiges, meinst du.
Wie habe ich das denn zu bewerten, dass ich das jetzt sehe? Also was ich zum Beispiel sehr interessant fand, ich manchmal muss ich ja mit der Bahn fahren. Und da gibt es ja WLAN. Wenn man dann von dem WLAN in das Internet möchte, dann geht das in der Regel nicht. Aber da muss man drei Knöpfe drücken. Nämlich irgendwie Hotspot-Login, jetzt online gehen, jetzt echt mal ins Internet.
Und jetzt lossurfen.
Und ich weiß, was ich tue.
Und am Ende kommt jetzt lossurfen. Jetzt lossurfen hat einfach gar keine Funktion mehr. Das ist einfach nur, mach noch mal einen Knopf dahin. Dann drückst du da drauf und dann kommt irgendwie Werbung oder so.
Dafür ist da dieses hübsche Foto von der glücklichen Familie, die da hier oben eingeblendet ist. Feelgood mit T-Mobile.
Sind die da jetzt schon einfach in voraus allen im Gehorsam? Haben die da jetzt ihre Hotspot schon dahin zu sowas umkonfiguriert? Oder probieren die das einfach mal?
Also ich glaube, das hat jetzt mit dem aktuellen Gesetzentwurf nichts zu tun, sondern man muss ja einfach sagen, es herrschte große Rechtsunsicherheit oder herrscht im Grunde ja bis heute noch und niemand weiß so richtig, was man denn eigentlich tun muss als Hotspotbetreiber, um nicht mehr zu haften. Also die Freifunker helfen sich ja im Grunde damit, dass sie den Datenverkehr ins Ausland tunneln. Das ist immer eine gute Idee. Aber das geht ja irgendwie nicht, wenn man T-Mobile ist, dann ist man ja ein nationaler Provider und dann will man sich ja irgendwie nicht die Blöße geben, irgendwie über Schweden zu gehen. Und deswegen denke ich, haben die sich einfach von ihrer Rechtsabteilung irgendwas schreiben lassen, an Vermerken, wie man dieses Problem Störerhaftung umgehen könnte. Und vermutlich ist da irgendein kreativer Jurist auf die Idee gekommen, machen wir doch mal eine Vorschaltseite und lassen wir doch die Leute einfach mal irgendwas abnicken. Denn einfach weil es keine klare Rechtslage gibt bisher, kann man dann immer vor dem Gericht sagen, naja, liebe Leute, wir haben doch hier wirklich alles getan, was wir tun konnten und kann dann halt hoffen, dass es reicht. Ich denke, das ist letztlich so eine Art Schrot-Schuss. Man macht einfach mal irgendwas, in der Hoffnung, dass man im Zweifelfang raus ist. Wobei man sagen muss, also Provider haben ja in aller Regel auch heute schon kein Problem. Also große Provider, wenn sie WLANs anbieten. Das muss man schon auch mal fairerweise sagen. Also das ist auch so ein bisschen übervorsichtig. Also bislang ist mir jedenfalls kein Fall bekannt, wo ein großer Provider abgemahnt worden wäre, sondern es geht ja immer um Abmahnungen gegen quasi nebenbei Provider. Also keine Ahnung, Cafés oder Privatleute, die nebenbei so ein WLAN betreiben.
Es scheint aber wirklich, wie fern wäre denn da meine Verschwörungstheorie, dass das eben eigentlich nur, also im Prinzip die Hotspot-Betreiber sagen, wir müssen irgendwas schaffen, damit wir ein Geschäftsmodell haben, nicht irgendwelche straffreien Idealisten uns das Geschäftsmodell kaputt machen.
Ja, ganz offensichtlich. Das konnte man ja live beobachten, weil die CDU-Fraktion eben einen solchen, wie soll ich sagen, einen solchen Hotspot-Betreiber eingeladen hat.
Und dem ist nichts Klügeres eingefallen?
Nein, der hat einfach nur sein Geschäftsmodell verteidigt. Der hat im Wesentlichen gesagt, wir haben in Deutschland kein Problem mit offenen WLANs. Wir bieten nämlich immerhin schon ein paar Tausend an und ihr müsst alle nur bei uns Kunden werden, dann wird alles gut. Das war so jetzt mal Bottom-Line dessen, was er gesagt hat. Das war schon unverfroren. Das steht sogar in der Stellungnahme. Also wer Lust hat, kann sich das von der Bundestags-Homepage runterladen.
Das wollte ich nicht machen.
Das ist richtig krass gewesen.
So, letztes Thema?
Ja, mögt ihr noch? Datenschutz? TTT.
Datenschutz, ich meine, da kommt doch jeder nochmal aus dem Bett raus.
Das war so ein richtiges Thema.
Ja, weil es auch wieder so ein Feelgood-Thema ist. Wir haben ja jetzt immerhin eine ernsthafte Aussicht, dass wir eine einheitliche Rechtslage im Bereich Datenschutz bekommen in Europa. Stichwort Datenschutzgrundverordnung. Auch an dieser Stelle nochmal einen Prost auf Jan-Philipp Albrecht, der mit Ralf Bendrath zusammen, ich glaube, sie sind beide hier, dafür gesorgt haben, dass wir, glaube ich, wirklich einen vernünftigen Rechtsrahmen bekommen. Der hat auch seine kleinen Macken, Stichwort Pressefreiheit, Meinungsfreiheit. Da gibt es auch so ein paar Ecken, wo ich sagen würde, das wird noch spannend. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, denke ich, ist das eine Regelung, mit der wir werden leben können. Aus der sich was machen lässt. Sehr schön.
Und dann hatten wir ja heute noch, da bin ich ja ganz stolz drauf, ich habe es ja geschafft, Max Schrems zu erreichen, der schafft inzwischen noch nicht mal mehr die Tagesschau. Und den hatten wir, der hat heute einen Vortrag gehalten über diese ganze Safe Harbor-Geschichte, der sehr wohlrezipiert war, weil er auch ein sehr guter Vortragender ist. Deswegen empfehle ich den ungesehen. Was glaubst du, wie sieht es bei dieser ganzen Safe Harbor-Geschichte aus? Was ist da deine Erwartung, wie damit jetzt umgegangen werden wird?
Es ist glaube ich noch nicht ganz absehbar, wie das auf europäischer Seite passiert. Was ich aber mit Sicherheit sagen kann, ist, dass der Schuss quasi in den Vereinigten Staaten gehört worden ist. Ich habe da mit verschiedenen Anwälten auch Kontakt, die Internetfirmen beraten in den USA. Da machen sich jetzt noch sehr viele Gedanken darüber, wie sie ihre Geschäftsmodelle einfach anpassen können an den Rechtsrahmen, der in Europa kommt. Jetzt, wo die Safe Harbor weg ist, schaut man sich einfach an, was steht in der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung und versucht die eigenen Geschäftsmodelle, soweit es irgendwie geht, daran anzupassen. Ich glaube, wenn wir so weitermachen, dann schaffen wir es tatsächlich, dass jedenfalls so die Grundprinzipien im Datenschutzrecht in Europa ein Stück weit zum Exportschlager werden. Einfach weil amerikanische Firmen sagen, das kann es nicht sein, dass wir hier ständig auf so tünneren Füßen stehen mit unseren Geschäftsmodellen. Die haben da einfach eine andere Vorstellung in Europa und wir werden einfach ein Stück weit in die Richtung kommen müssen. Das sagen einem inzwischen auch amerikanische Aktivisten. Also wenn wir das Datenschutzniveau in Amerika ändern wollen, dann wird das niemals über den Kongress gehen. Dazu gibt es einfach viel zu viel Lobbydruck. Aber die Europäer können es schaffen, dass wir hier quasi bei uns zu Hause auch vernünftige Datenschutzstandards bekommen. Und das wiederum, finde ich, ist keine schlechte Nachricht.
Das ist ja ein Füllhorn von guten Nachrichten. Das ist eigentlich gar keine richtige Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Meinst du, da brauchen wir noch so ein bisschen Chaos-Technik?
So viele schöne, gute Nachrichten.
Ein bisschen kann man das auch mal so stehen lassen.
Im Rahmen der Jahresendfeierlichkeiten, finde ich, kann man das schon mal machen.
Hast du noch irgendwelche persönlichen Anmerkungen?
Ist schön bei euch und ein bisschen warm. Ist warm, ja.
Auch das Bier ist warm. Das ist übrigens BND-Breu.
BND-Breu ist schwarz-braun und undurchsichtig.
Und massiv Bodensatz. Brauner Bodensatz.
Und geht ganz schön in die Birne.
Bei der Hitze komme ich heute noch auf meine sechs Duschen. Stimmt, sechs Duschen, eine Stunde Schlaf.
Zwei Mahlzeiten und eine Stunde Schlaf.
Ja, Linus. Und für uns geht auch wieder mal ein Podcastjahr zu Ende. Jetzt haben wir schon über vier Jahre hier rumgesendet.
Und? Jetzt kriege ich ein Geschenk.
Ja, du hast ein weiteres Jahr mit mir gewonnen. Ja, kannst dich schon mal drauf freuen. Genau, wir machen nämlich weiter.
Was ist denn mit dem kleinen Klopfer? Ich dachte, der ist für Linus.
Weiß ich nicht, hier gibt es auch noch.
Kleiner Klopfer mit Feige.
Lakritz-Likör mit Pfeffer, Bohnenkamp. Ich weiß auch nicht, die haben da heute eine Lkw-Ladung von kleinen alkoholischen Flaschen und verteilen die jetzt gleichmäßig.
Den Bohnenkamp finde ich ja ganz attraktiv.
Ja, der räumt ja dann den Magen auf, heißt das. Oder war das was anderes? Nein, das war was anderes. Wir sind jetzt auch schon nicht mehr so ganz in der Zeit. Aber wir können ja auch mal plötzlich aufhören, oder?
Ja, machen wir jetzt auch.
Machen wir einfach mal so.
Vielen Dank, Ulf.
Und für die Anmerkungen zu diesem Jahr. Und vielen Dank, Linus, für deine immer wieder beständigen, ihr wisst gar nicht, wie dieser Mensch schuftet, um irgendwie diese Sendung vorzubereiten, dem einfach die große Last der inhaltlichen Vorbereitung aufliegt. Und das ist auch auf jeden Fall noch mal ein Applaus wert. Vielen Dank. Ja, und vor allem auch vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Die ist nämlich auch da und die finden wir auch total super. Und das hilft auch enorm, da entsprechenden Zuspruch zu erfahren. Und umso mehr war super, auch so viele Leute hier auf einen Haufen zu sehen. Und jetzt machen wir hier Schluss und gehen noch ein bisschen feiern und haben Spaß.